"Do the Roast Yourself Challange please"
"Can't wait for Pewdiepie's Roast Yourself Challenge"
"Felix where is the roast yourself challenge"
"You got called out by Keemstar."
"I seriously want pewdiepie to do the roast yourself challenge."
Roast yourself challenge.
Hey guys whats up.
So Ryan Higa created a challenge called the roast yourself challenge
where you roast yourself?
I haven't even started already feeling culturally appropriative
Oh God the rapping!
Meanwhile your album 'Gold'
Might as well have never even been sold.
Oh god no! Why are they rapping?
[RAPS ENDLESSLY]
[POODS BACKING AWAY]
What the fuck! Why?
[CONTINUES TO RAP]
Oh god why!
[POODS GROANING]
Mister Neil deGrasse Tyson
Please...
Memefy my feelings
Roast yourself challenge more like cringe montage compilation.
I was going to make a joke that this video gave me cancer but...
My channel is too big for me to make those kind of jokes.
Do you really need a challenge for you to admit your past failures.
Sounds pretty damn easy.
Do I even have to point out that the challenge is used just as a way to get more views?
Which you know by the way I would never fucking do.
I have integrity.
If this video gets a 100,000 likes, I'll upload another challenge video.
You think your fans eat up all that shit?
Boohoo. I'm not relevant as I used to be.
Boohoo. My fans see me as this one thing when I wanna be another thing.
You're all a bunch of crybabies.
And I know what you're thinking
But Pewdiepie, you do all these things too. You're a hypocrite.
Yeah. Have I ever pretend to be anything else?
How about y'all get some fucking friends to roast you?
You know, like every roast is supposed to be.
The only reason your friends don't roast you is because they hate you and it would be too real.
Excuse me while I hold my phone while I read this one line.
Because remembering a couple of lyrics is clearly too fucking hard for my brain.
Y'all so bad at roasting, RoastKid1907 will fucking destroy you.
Hey!
I'm roasting the roast yourself challenge. You got it.
You finally picked up on it huh?
The video is pretty much the worst one out of all of them.
I literally put no effort in it.
Where I try to be edgy and call out the other YouTubers on their bullshit
Eventhough I still do the same fucking thing
Well at least this video will get more views.
Why am I not roasting myself?
Because everyone already knows that I'm pure garbage.
But mainly, because no matter what the fuck you say to me
Ain't nothing's gonna make this face give a shit.
Alright fine. I'll do a diss track.
It can't be that hard.
Stop rapping.